peu
[Musique]
ils sont réduits leçons du cela dès
qu'ils ont entendu je grille
elle va mourir
à
[Musique]
ils sont venus ils sont tous là
même ceux du sud de l'italie y'a même
georgiou depuis ce maudit avec des
présents plein les bras
plus enfants
s'ils n'entrent autour du 10e
mais le jeune homme a d'abord
c'est un peu leur délit
[Musique]
on
où
on la réchauffe de bg lui revendre ses
oreillers
elle va mourir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de marie mena de grâce dans la statue
sur la place bien sûr
pour lui tendait les bras en lui
chantant à
rires
oui
amen
[Musique]
toi
là
iata
et de six
[Musique]
toi
brown
[Musique]
tous les hommes aussi chaud
sur les chemins de grand soleil elle va
mourir
à
rapport
[Musique]
après le ballon
de bons vins de l'abattre
tandis que s'entassent pêle mêle
sur yb a foulé et chapeau
ces troubles sociaux papistes près du
gros
y'a même nom
thalys du jour
dans une
ah la la
les femmes se sur les échanges entre
je te réveiller
les favoris
bah
[Musique]
doucement les yeux fermés chaque
commerce à nos enfants
après une bonne journée
google suit
machado
et
[Musique]
obama
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand le
toi toi
[Musique]
on y attend
temps
où
là
tout est ouvert
babel
jamais
jules ou tu devras
[Musique]